the complete schedule and you can find
behind-the-scenes photos and videos on
twitter at book TV is our twitter handle
on instagram book underscore TV and
facebook.com slash book TV now starting
now here's Jessica Luthor on the culture
and politics of sexual assault in
relation to college sports
good afternoon
get started thank you all for being here
welcome this beautiful fall afternoon
here in the great state of Texas
we are excited today to talk to you a
little bit about football it is fall
after all here in Texas and I think
currently we have the UT Longhorns are
playing Texas Tech I'm not sure what the
score is there I know that we all right
yeah okay Charlie Strong all right we
also have in my alma mater Texas A&M
University planned it gets Ole Miss
again not sure what the score is there
and then later I know we have Baylor
against TCU so we have some great
football games going on but today what
we want to talk about is the
intersection of football and college
sports with sexual violence and sexual
assault my name is Rosa Luna
I am from Bartlett Texas a huge football
town it's a one-eighth a very small
rural town but it's a huge football town
and we were a team of the decades in the
90s shows my age but also we went three
state championships during that time
so again football has is ingrained not
only in myself but just around the state
of Texas and Beyond and from there
graduated from Texas A&M University
again another huge college town and so
you can imagine my cognitive dissonance
every every week in the during the fall
what I get excited about football games
but at the same time being the deputy
director at the Texas Association to get
sexual assault I know the reality of
sexual assault on campuses and I know
the reality in the dynamics of college
sports and young men and young women
that are going to colleges so and a lot
of that we owe a great deal a great deal
of gratitude to both Jessica loose
Luther and Daniel Salomon for the work
that they've done in uncovering a lot of
the stories some at Baylor and also the
work that went into the book
unsportsmanlike conduct college football
and the politics of rape so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna I'm gonna go
ahead and have each of them introduce
themselves and then Jessica and Dan will
then follow up with what they've been
working on and then I'll do a couple of
questions and then we'll take a couple
questions from you so we'll start with
Rick
ayuh good morning or afternoon everyone
my name is Rick get rich and I work
along side rows of the Texas Association
against sexual assault I hail from San
Antonio and the work that we do is very
specific to being a voice for survivors
in our state and also working directly
with the over 85 different sexual
assault programs that make up kind of
the population and the geography of
Texas so I'm excited to be here and
looking forward to hearing what Jessica
and Dan have to say and also hearing
your questions as well so thank you my
name is Dan Solomon and I'm a reporter
with Texas Monthly and I've been working
with Jessica on covering Baylor for the
past 14 months or so and still working
on that story that never ends I am
[Music]
Oh reported he's had six monthly last
August of 2015
sort of broke open the baler short hey
y'all okay I'm gonna keep okay we're all
awake now that's good so I wanted to
talk a little bit about horses we're
here at the second Book Festival I went
to Florida State I was born into Florida
State football fandom from my dad and my
mom and especially my dad and I watched
a lot of games when back in the day
where there was one television in the
house and you know I only applied to one
school I was gonna go to Florida State
and that's where I went I went to every
home game one time I actually physically
hurt myself and I was on crutches and
the one thing the doctor said was like
don't go to the football game and so of
course I was like 20 and I went to the
football game and so people asked me a
lot like where the book came from and it
really came out of my fandom and the
fact that I care about the issue of
sexual violence and so this is a pretty
well-known story but in November 2013
the then quarterback of Florida State
Jameis Winston it came out that he had
been under investigation for sexual
assault for 11 months and at that point
the Tallahassee Police Department had
not really done anything with the case
Florida State had not been very good at
football at that point for a few years
it was very exciting that season we had
a team we have an offensive line and we
had this amazing quarterback behind the
o-line
and there was Heisman chatter by
November which he went on spend the
Heisman there was chatter that we were
you know maybe good enough to go with a
national championship which we ended up
winning that year and so it became this
huge and national story because the
Tallahassee the police department
finally forwarded the case on to the
state's attorney eleven months later and
we waited for a few weeks to find out
whether or not he'd be charged which he
was not and at that point in time I was
following everything because I was a fan
and I just did not like how we covered
this topic and that's when I started to
intervene and I think it's important for
me to say that there are studies that
suggest that athletes commit more
violence than other students but I I
don't like to talk about it like that I
get nervous that we then don't talk
about all the other perpetrators of
violence both on college campuses within
our society in general I think we talk
about it more when it involves football
players or basketball players there's an
intense fandom around college sports as
soon as you report on any university you
learn pretty quickly how intense that
fandom is people just care a whole lot
when a player gets in trouble and it
might impact the ability for their team
to win games so we end up talking about
it a lot so for me that's my
intervention
I want to intervene when we're talking
about it so I ended up writing a lot
about Florida State other at this point
that I think that's a school that I've
written the most about Baylor sort of
spots in a second there and then I was
asked to write this book and I actually
was pretty nervous about doing it I was
nervous that people would be mad at me
but more than that I you know two and a
half years ago I thought no one will
care about this when the book comes out
I'm incredibly heartened to be sitting
here thankful to the Texas Book Festival
but to have me and the fact that you all
are here to talk about this the fact
that people show up to have this
conversation over and over again with me
god that's one of the things that gives
me hope so the book itself is set up to
look at this as a systemic issue within
the sport rather than an individual case
that's often how we consume it it's one
player it's one coach it's one
University and it's pretty easy to then
see those things as isolated and while I
think obviously that that work is
important and I do that work too
it was it was great for me to be able to
look at this on a systemic level and
talk about the ways that this repeats
over and over and over again at a lot of
different schools from Division one to
Division three it doesn't money doesn't
matter for division one football but we
see these same things happening at
Division three when a case breaks what
coaches say what they do and do not do
how the media doesn't does not cover it
the words that we use the fact that the
NCAA the National Collegiate Athletic
Association really only pays lip service
to this issue and likes to push it off
onto anyone else that they can so I
really do try to I want I argue strongly
in the book that this is a systemic
issue within the sport but as especially
brick and rose can talk about like this
is a systemic issue outside of just
football there are particulars to it we
can talk about that if you guys want but
I also in the book it's a hard there's a
hard book to write this topic is hard to
write on it's sad a lot of the time it's
just really sad but it was important to
me that the end of the book be about
solutions possible changes that we can
make so about a third of the book at the
end there's 13 chapters where I suggest
things that could be better that we
could do better in order to make the
sport better you know talk about this
issue better things like I start the
whole that whole section off by talking
about
and education I'm a huge proponent of
prevention we've been doing a lot of
punitive stuff for a long time around
this and that clearly hasn't worked very
well but I started off with consensus I
figure if you only make it five pages in
to that section at least I will have
gotten you to read a little bit about
consent but it's stuff like we need to
hire more women and everywhere but also
specifically within college sports
administration within teams put them in
locker rooms they just need to be in
these spaces a lot more than they are
and then about a year and a half ago I
wrote a chapter about holding people at
the top of the system accountable so I
try in the book very hard to focus on
the people at the top we can talk about
an individual case we can talk about a
player and what happened in that one but
I want to talk about why this
perpetuates over and over and over and
over again and the people that are there
over and over and over again our coaches
athletic directors university presidents
the same sports media and so I have a
chapter where I argue that those guys
need to be held accountable when thing
when there is cultural failure in a
program or at a university and we've
seen a little bit of that at Baylor a
little walking back right now it's very
complicated but but that's what the book
does and I'm gonna like I'm gonna now
I'm gonna pass the football that's
terrible - Dan so to talk a little bit
about our work specifically with Baylor
which highlights a lot of the stuff that
I talk about in the book sure yeah
so back in August of last year we got a
tip that there was a Baylor football
player who was
about to go to trial for sexual assault
that no one had written about and you
know you get tips a lot of the time that
don't seem like there's anything there
so you know he had an unusual name his
name was sambuca watchu and you know
googled him and tried to find some
information and couldn't find anything
we found that he had been you know he'd
played at Boise State that he had left
the program at Baylor he'd been he
wasn't practicing with the team but that
the team expected him back and as
recently as June the coach of said that
they'd expected him back on the field
that he had some personal issues but
nothing about a trial nothing about an
arrest nothing about sexual assault and
you know we kept sort of questioning it
and then I I found a copy of the the
docket from McLennan County that day and
saw that there was in fact a trial about
to happen with sambuca watchu so we
decided to go up to Waco and start
looking into what was going on there and
what we found was you know a lot of
somehow this story hadn't made it into
the press somehow the story hadn't you
know his name hadn't been reported even
in the courtroom you know the the court
reporters had missed it and so we
started looking into it and we went and
covered the trial of sambuca watchu and
we wrote about that and it ended up sort
of kick-starting this entire change of
the narrative I remember really clearly
you know I had Google Alerts and Twitter
you know alerts set up for sambuca
watch's name and for weeks so that we
were reporting the story they were very
nothing came up because nobody knew who
he was and then we published and he was
convicted a couple of hours after we
published our story and suddenly you
know those hashtags and those Google
Alerts were on fire and I would turn on
ESPN I would see sambuca watch whose
name it was very strange because up
until that point we were the only ones
who knew it and so you know reporting
about Baylor and reporting about sambuca
watchu has been really interesting to
see how this school and this case ended
up sort of being the flashpoint for a
lot of the conversation around sexual
assault in college football and a lot of
that's because they had two players
convicted as opposed to just accuse
so it's a lot harder to say well there's
a lot of side to this you know who knows
who's telling the truth like we have
actual adjudicated cases and convictions
and that's a big part of how I think
Baylor ended up sort of being at the
fore of the story and it's only you know
become more so as the you know the over
the past 14 months since uh Kawachi was
convicted we've you know learned that
there were many other players we've
learned that coaches you know took there
was an investigation conducted by a law
firm that investigates schools that have
these accusations of sexual assault
Baylor commissioned a law firm to come
and investigate them and what they found
was that there was a pattern of coaches
sort of handling things internally that
should have been handled by very
different entities and this kept going
on and you know right now Baylor is
still very much at a at a flashpoint
here where they have a lot of decisions
to make and you know they fired Art
Briles was their head coach at the time
they filed fired an Ian macaw who was
their athletics director he resigned
excuse me and Ken Starr the president
was demoted and then eventually they did
sort of a conscious uncoupling of that
relationship
thanks references but you know as this
has gone on you know there's still there
elements at Baylor who want our trials
back and there were you know there's
kind of a what looks to be a civil war
between forces at the school who want to
move past this and forces at the school
who really feel like you know their
glory days were really tied to our
trials and the football program being
what it was under him and you know there
are a lot of questions like there's as
many answers as we have and as much as
we've learned there's still many more
questions than there are answers in
terms of what does it look like when a
program decides to you know to clean
itself up is it possible to clean it up
and is it about football or is it about
the culture of the school is it about
the leadership of the school you know
who is leadership is it the president
and the coach or is it the people who
work under them who maybe handle the
day-to-day decisions and those are
questions that are really hard to answer
but they're things that we're trying to
learn because I think that you know
after you get past day one of the story
this is days one through 400 I want to
just add two things about Baylor one is
that you know sort of the unfolding of
the story we published in August there
was a huge brouhaha around all of that
start has centered multiple times that
he commissioned pepper Hamilton because
of our reporting and then there was sort
of a lull and early in the year this
year a survivor wrote a blog post about
her experience at Baylor and it went
viral and in response and this is a
normal response a lot of other survivors
started to come forward that we've been
watching that in the presidential
election that's a normal thing that
happens when a survivor tells her story
and so I want to give a lot of credit to
the survivors who come forward and tell
their stories there
huge reason that these things get out
there and it's very hard to do that and
to be in the public in that way we're
not very kind to survivors in the ports
then there was additional reporting
especially at ESPN that really pushed
everything so by the time pepper
Hamilton actually released their report
there was yet again the sort of wave of
news around everything and then I can't
now remember what else I was gonna say
about oh I wanted to say I got it
one of the things about pepper Hamilton
I know we're here to talk about college
football because that's what my book is
on and we're in Texas but one of the
things about pepper Hamilton and it's
very clear while there was definitely
failure in the athletic department and
they are clear on that point it was a
institutional failure as Dan mentioned
right they this was not just football
players who are doing this violence on
campus and it was not just the victims
of those football players who faced
indifference when they went to report
right this was an issue throughout
campus and an issue for all kinds of
students and that of course suggests
there were all kinds of perpetrators of
these students as well in the student
population so it is important for us to
I mean I obviously care about this lens
of football but in the case of Baylor it
was obviously a much bigger issue than
just football but it was also football
okay so I wanted to acknowledge the work
again as I mentioned earlier of Dan and
Jessica because some of the things that
that Rick and I do working at the Texas
Association against sexual assault is we
are constantly challenging reporters
challenging the media on the angles in
which they report these stories the kind
of questions that they ask and I have to
say after reading this book and after
reading this story that they put
together on the Baylor situation we were
just jumping for joy if you will in our
office because of the way that it was
handled and I think that you all could
write a book on how to handle reporting
those types of stories so what I wanted
to also say is that here in Texas we're
very lucky everybody do everything
bigger here in Texas where everyone
knows that but we also have our
set of statistics in regards to sexual
assault normally before this we would
use set result stats that were just
national stats but with the Institute of
domestic violence and sexual assault
pals out of the School of Social Work
here at UT Austin what they found is
that one in five Texas men and two and
five Texas women have experienced sexual
assault at some point in their lifetime
that equates to 6.3 million Texans also
what they found is that over 90% did not
report to law enforcement so my question
is for the panel being that college
campuses are a microcosm of our larger
society is there anything Jessica and
Dan that you all saw with your work
doing this work in what the actions or
lack thereof of law enforcement if that
contributed to the culture of silence
around these cases oh wow that's a good
question yes I think anytime you look at
one of these cases or any particular
institution you're gonna find that sort
of people are nervous to go to law
enforcement you know it's if you think
about it it's very difficult to report
this kind of crime I mean there's often
a lot of trauma involved and then you
are telling your story over and over and
over again and you're often met with
someone who is skeptical of what you're
saying and part of what they're doing is
questioning whether or not you are lying
about this traumatic thing that you are
trying to report you know if you have
for the person who's been accused if you
have a good offense defense attorney
they will make sure that you never tell
your story anywhere if they can help it
right so there's one side of this that
ends up telling our story over and over
again and we as a society really enjoy
picking those stories apart it's kind of
this morbid pastime that we have to say
well you told your story seven times you
change this detail three times therefore
I can't trust any of your story
and law enforcement participates in this
they do the same kind of work people get
nervous about that I mean one of the
things that this Institute is doing here
at UT is actually creating there's a
great blueprint you can go and download
it I think Obama's mentioned it before
to help campus police especially first
responders most of the time survivors
and I'm sure that Rick can speak to this
specifically really just want someone
compassionate who's going to listen to
them and just hear what they have to say
and they often just feel like they're
they're met with indifference it's
always the word that I use like and so
yeah I don't know if I have anything
specific necessarily from but this is a
common thing that you hear about and
this is also true I want to say with
reporting to the institution it's the
college university as well the same sort
of fear of and difference in the picking
a part of every little thing that
they're going to say about this
traumatic thing violent thing that has
happened to them and I think that you
know one of the issues here is that
investigators are trained to be
skeptical that's part of being an
investigator but they're not necessarily
aware of the way that trauma informs
memory and so you have investigators who
are skeptical of people who suffer
trauma and it kind of self reinforces
the idea that they're not going to be
believed because they're not going to
tell their story as consistently as
someone whose story doesn't involve
direct first-hand trauma and that's I
think an important part of why
investigators sort of seem indifferent
or do a bad job frankly because they
don't have the training necessary or the
it goes against your instincts to hear
the same story in different ways and
assume that it's true but what research
and and the actual science of that
indicates is that it actually is
so one of the one of the reasons why
rose and I are here is to kind of talk
about the advocacy perspective and the
support that we can provide for
survivors so just so you know we've been
saying Texas Association against sexual
assault we didn't tell you where we are
we are actually here in Austin we are
the state coalition every state in the
country has a coalition like us and we
work specifically to ensure that no
survivor gets left behind and that the
systems and the programs and the folks
that we work with across the state have
the capacity in order to work and
respond when a survivor makes an outcry
with that being said I want to I'll say
two things real quick one is that this
isn't a normal everyday conversation we
recognize that we want it to be we want
our community to be really involved in
talking about these issues without it
being so scary and uncomfortable and so
that being said I want to acknowledge
that there may be some survivors that
are sitting among us and this
conversation might be triggering for you
this conversation might bring up some
stuff that you maybe you've never dealt
with or you've never even told anyone
please know that you are supported and
that we definitely understand that you
need to take care of yourself when you
need to take care of yourself and that
Rose and myself and Dan and Jessica are
here for you after if you need to talk
to us about anything at all I just want
to make sure that we acknowledge the
fact that some of us in this room have
been through this what I do know as well
is that almost every single one of us
knows at least one person in our lives
if it's not us who has been through this
as well so this hits close to home so on
the reporting side again coming from a
community perspective one of the things
that I find that I found really
interesting in working at a sexual
assault program is that we knew that we
were seeing students we knew that a lot
of college students were coming in and
getting counseling or they were getting
case management or they were calling our
hotline
and then we kind of looked at the stats
and the reports on the campus but going
to the campus website and trying to find
how many sexual assaults were reported
and we were finding zero we were finding
one we were finding none and and that
was a huge disparity and and and it made
us step back and say why what is
happening why are survivors not
comfortable or are they afraid so we had
to kind of investigate and and not
really investigate but we had to kind of
meet the campuses where they were and to
ask questions what can we do to help how
can we increase your capacity what do we
need to do to change things your climate
to where your students if something
happens to them feel supported and
hopefully those reports will go up it's
unfortunate that they will go up but
they will but when you look at it from
the good side that means that that the
campus is doing its job and the
community is the one who's holding that
campus accountable as well so thank you
I have another question that I'd like to
hear each of your responses to if that's
okay Rick we'll start with you
how do you respond to college coaches or
the fandom as as Jessica mentioned
whenever we have transfer athletes in
whatever sport that have a sexual
assault allegation and the response is
well let's wait on a criminal conviction
if there's no criminal conviction then
there's nothing to worry about
what what is your response to that yeah
that's a tough one it really is because
I think just as a society in general you
know we we may not be trained or
understand how complex these issues are
and so for a lot of us we find comfort
we find solace in knowing whether this
person was found guilty or not guilty
so if they were found guilty then you
know there are people who feel that's an
incredible injustice and there are other
people who feel like okay we got justice
and you
that serves for how this person's going
to be either treated or represented or
where they're allowed to go on campus or
if they're allowed to come back on
campus and we're talking about in the
criminal justice system but I think what
happens a lot of times is when someone
is not adjudicated or someone does not
get a conviction I think we have a
tendency to sometimes say you see it
didn't happen and so then the onus of
proof for the onus of responsibility or
accountability goes back to the survivor
and then they're the focus now right and
so we we're very forgiving community
sometimes and so I think if we rely on
conviction rates it might disappoint us
because our conviction rates are very
very very low and so what again I think
is important is that you know Jessica
talked a lot about accountability I
think the ones that need to hold
campuses and administrators accountable
are the students who actually go there
as well and the community specifically
if it's a small community where that
campus lives plays and works so yeah you
know if you don't add I think that one
thing that's important to remember you
know when we were reporting on watchu
for example you would hear people talk
about how like well you know the jury
knows better than anybody what happened
the jury has more information than
anybody and there's this idea that a
conviction magically transforms a person
from you know not guilty to guilty and
that's not obviously how it works and
you know often like the jury in the
ukalachan case knew less about it than
we did because they would have to leave
the room when things were being
discussed so there were things that the
you know the jurors actually don't know
that are true and you know so there's
this kind of idea that a jury and a
conviction
you know magically transforms a person
into guilty and that's not obviously how
it works but when it comes to you know
title nine and things like that one of
the things that I think it's really
important to remember is that this is
people refer to it as like an extra
legal system if they're critical of it
and this idea that it's kind of an extra
you know the place for people to be held
you know to be charged with a crime and
that's not really what it's about what
it's really about is
that the victim has equal opportunity to
access their education and so when we
talk about like well should we wait and
see if there's a conviction the person
who's in school with that with the
student with the the person who attacked
them still has to go to school and often
they still have to be in class with that
person and that's a really hard thing
for a person to to encounter and a
person to live with and so it's not
really about like we think of it sort of
as holding the perpetrator accountable
but it's that's not exactly what title 9
is all about it's mostly about making
sure that the victim has the access to
her education or his education of the
depending on the situation but that the
victim has access to their education
without having to be confronted with the
hospital environment created by being in
class with their attacker if I could
talk to a coach about transfer students
that'd be amazing I the thing that I
like to say about transfer you know this
happens a lot someone will get in
trouble at one school and they'll
transfer to a new school this happens
with coaches as well so I don't want to
say this is just on players but you know
there are now two conferences the FCC in
the big 12 that say if you are dismissed
from a team because you committed
violence against women then you cannot
transfer in to their programs but the
thing that you know you asked about the
next time that if they if they recommit
um so I'm gonna just ignore that and say
at the moment of transfer I think we
should be pushing these coaches and
asking them what are you doing for these
guys these guys that you're bringing
into your community onto your team to
the University like if you know that
they've struggled and had trouble at
their other school like what are you
doing for them now like what one of my
questions about Baylor is what did the
same week watch a good health when he
came in to Waco like was he going to
counseling I would anyone who hears this
that can answer that question and wants
to contact us and tell us that that
would be great like I would really like
to know what it is the teams are doing
for these players I obviously care very
much for the women
and what happens to them once they
report and whether or not the community
is taking care of them and doing
preventative education around all these
things but I also think in those moments
in particular we should be pushing to
find out what are they doing for the
players to write what it what's the work
that's being done well I think what
we'll do is take some questions from the
audience if anyone has a question that
they'd like to ask the panel please come
forward
writing and reporting process were you
in the courtroom every day you know how
did you decide on the day to day three
coverage thank you sure well we started
reporting on August 5th and we reported
for about 10 days straight we had one
day where we didn't I remember because I
watched the flash that whole day but
otherwise we were reporting like all day
the whole time we were awake and we went
to jury selection on that Monday we went
to day two of the trial and you know at
that point we were we knew what the
story was and we had heard from a lot of
the witnesses that we were hoping to
hear from on the stand so I don't I
think at that point we were really
writing those last two days bleeding out
we published on a Thursday I think there
was an intense writing and drafting and
editing and fact-checking that were
happening on those two days but yeah we
we can both talk about this I guess but
in our partnership we worked really well
together dan and I and that I'm an
tensely detail-oriented to the point
where it can be like too much don't
laughs Dan and and so and Dan is amazing
at sort of the overall narrative and
understanding how to tell the story and
what needs to make it in and what
doesn't and those two things come
together really well in our writing so
we're able to tell I mean Dan is a
phenomenal writer as well and he's a you
know we're able to tell incredibly good
stories but I'm there like nitpicking
every little piece that makes it into it
like I can tell you the dates of a whole
bevy of things that have happened with
Baylor I just that's sort of the thing
that I do it's super helpful by the way
to have someone that detail-oriented if
you're trying to write quickly because
that means that the mistakes that a fast
writer tends to make gets smoothed over
by a very diligent fat tiger
you've done you've done some amazing
work with with Baylor and with
everything after that so something that
I saw today that was trending was a
hashtag CA B I know I guess Baylor is
selling coach Art Briles t-shirts and I
know earlier this week the assistants
like they reached they they sent out
that whole letter about that truth don't
lie so I've got to ask you guys you
knows people who have been reporting
what will it take for both Baylor and
the fans of Baylor some of my assume are
probably here to like actually get it
like when will they actually get I mean
that's a good question fans are can be
so incredibly intense in a way that I
don't even at someone who used to be a
very intense fan I sometimes struggle
with understanding and the thing that I
do is I try to just remind them all the
time that the victims and the Baylor
case are all of these women who came
forward and reported and very little was
done for them at this point I believe it
is 17 women and 19 players on the
football team alone and we know that
that is ten percent or you know of all
the reported cases at Baylor so like
part of the work that I do is just
reminding people all the time and if it
sounds ridiculous when you say it out
loud but that there are survivors and
like that's who we should be centering
when we talk about this and it gets lost
in the moments of you know see a B and
the truth don't lie and these kind of
things and I try to just recenter over
and over again to remind people that
that's who we should be talking about I
mean it's really tough like fandom is
important to people it you know like
this is you know this is the first time
in like a month I've left my house not
wearing a Cubs hat like it matters you
know and that's like it brings people
together it is an important part of
communities but it is really you have to
kind of have this walt up that says that
the victims aren't also part of your
community in order for to sell the coach
our trials t-shirt you have to forget
that they really are you know they were
also Baylor and that's a really
important thing to keep in mind but it's
not the fun part it's not you know
cheering for you know your team it's not
thinking but maybe you're gonna make it
to the playoff like that's the part that
that is harder but it's definitely still
part of your community thank you very
much for your work really appreciate it
my question is probably more for roles I
suppose because Rose you said that you
part of your work is to challenge the
media in the ways in which they report
could you expound on that a little bit
more as to how you actually do that yes
before I was deputy director at the at
tossa I was the communications director
and Rick can also speak to this he was
communications director right before
that what we do is oftentimes Matassa is
called whenever there is a huge
high-profile story so we put out talking
points for our local rape crisis center
so that we can all get on the same page
but also whenever there's just a story
as we're going through social media or
as things pop up in our news feed we see
things like 47 year old teacher has sex
with 12 year old student things like
that that's that's an egregious example
but that happens all the time even and
also in response to non a non stranger
adult cases it's really really hard to
get the angle that it needs to be which
is why I was so appreciative of the work
that Dan and Jessica did because they
asked all the right questions and I mean
it when I say that they could actually
to a workshop or write a book on how to
to report these cases in in a survivor
centered way Rick do you want to add to
that yeah so that's a great question by
the way and so for us it's about just to
expand on what Rose is talking about you
know it's not that a 47 year old had sex
with a 13 year old it's that's rape it's
sexual assault and it's sexual violence
so we need to call it that I think a lot
of times our work with the media is
getting them to reframe things that
things are not sometimes sex scandals
they are issues of sexual violence and
rape
when you have a young girl who is
pregnant that's not just an issue of
teen pregnancy it's also could
potentially be an issue of sexual
violence and so our job is to respond to
the media and to inform them on other
ways that they can look at reporting
something and to really kind of make
good on survivors and report it as it
truly is because that is what survivors
want to hear when we use stuff like sex
scandal or just it was just sex we
minimize what a survivor might have gone
through by not calling it exactly what
it is
so that's part of part of the work that
we do
of alcohol and it's contributing role
its excuse role for perpetrators and its
way of blaming victims so so that's a
really that's a great question thank you
for bringing that up and that's
something that I think has been used in
the past as an excuse but that's not it
so what will say the truth the facts are
that in these cases of sexual assault
alcohol is present did it cause it
absolutely not the perpetrator caused
the sexual assault so I think well we we
have to be careful in how we frame and
talk about alcohol in the role of sexual
assault especially on a college campus
because that could very quickly turn
into blaming the victim and excusing the
perpetrator but and I will I will add
one thing to this as well is that I
think for a lot of survivors too we we
really need to shift the conversation
because there are a number of survivors
who might have been underage while they
were drinking and they might be afraid
to come forth to report it because they
were underage thinking that the priority
or that the focus is going to be on what
they did wrong versus on the sexual
assault and so that that I think is
another conversation that we need to
have and what we found is that a lot of
campuses are shifting how they
investigate and how they look at that so
so that survivors don't feel like I'm
gonna get in trouble because I was doing
something wrong and that is not what we
want for survivors
thank you for addressing us on a very
important topic one thing that I heard
earlier that I that I thought was really
significant was she spoke briefly about
how complicated this really is we don't
want to be insensitive to a victim we
want to care for the victim we also
don't want to quickly and incorrectly
brand somebody a rapist so these are
complicated questions and it seems to me
that we have a lot of we do have some
journalists out there that just enjoy
sort of Hey look at how this university
blew it you know look at how Bay look
how many mistakes Thaler made look how
many mistakes Harvard made just point
see hindsight is twenty-twenty pointing
at mistakes that universities have made
and so my very specific question for you
is do we have something other than just
theater going on here do we have public
advocacy groups do we have legal groups
do we have institutions that have said
if you are a university or you are an
institution of higher learning and
somebody comes forward with an
allegation of sexual assault here are
the 10 commandments or the 10 guidelines
that you should follow in order to
thoughtfully carefully properly go
through an investigation that respects
the concerns of both sides do we have
any specific organization that is stuck
its neck out and specifically said this
is the way responsible universities
behave or is everybody just poking at
the Keystone Cops and the universities
are making it up as best they can as
they go along and we just have a lot of
theater I think Jessica and Dan could
probably on the federal level we do it's
the Department of Education and the
office on civil rights those are the
ones who are putting forth guidelines
regulations they're holding schools and
universities accountable and they kind
of regulate how title mine should be
carried out and carried through but in
y'all's work I don't know if you can
expand on that yeah I mean the DoD does
like very extensive guidelines that
universities should follow some are
mandates a lot of it is guidelines
I'm always relooking it up to make sure
that I get it right but they're
dedicated sites so that's just on the
federal level and their organization
especially student activists we've seen
a huge way like credit to the student
activists over the last four or five
years who really push this the for and
so there are a lot of resources out
there that you can access like know your
9 which is IX know your IX is an amazing
resourceful site that does really like
bullet point this the kind of stuff
you're asking for but it is complicated
and I will say like as a journalist
especially for me I survivors times I
can eat all the time that's a very
regular thing for me and it's almost
always when it's bad I almost never hear
the good and so that's part of it right
and something I recognize about the kind
of work that I'm doing and one I mean
one like I said the beginning one reason
I wrote the book is because it allowed
me to say sort of systemic things rather
than just bailer just Harvard just just
just I could say who here is the whole
thing all at once so there is stuff out
there but again it is still complicated
even sort of when you go and look at the
do E's list of guidelines it's long
universities have a lot of things they
have to meet in order to ensure that
they are protecting people's civil
rights and and that's hard work and part
of just to add to that part of our job
at NASA is real quick part of the work
that I focus on is is ensuring that
campuses across Texas are adhering to
the guidelines set forward to them that
if they have any issues or they have
problems or they have questions that
they can call us as the state coalition
call me we'll come out do technical
assistance we'll make sure that you your
policy looks good whatever they need
whatever support is is what we will
provide in kind of meeting a lot of
those guidelines that we refer them to a
lot of the stuff Jessica talked about so
we only have a few more minutes but we I
see we have two folks so we'll get both
your questions in and that's one of the
panel to be mindful that we are running
time but thank you guys both for your
excellent work in journalism I just have
tremendous admiration for your
supporting your reporting and also for
your advocacy work thank you guys so
much it takes both and my question has
to do with other institutions that may
bear some examination I'm thinking
specifically of fraternities in the
campus blueprint that Jessica mentioned
some of the risk factors that the campus
blueprint pointed out were membership in
a sorority and frequent attendance of
fraternity parties and there are also
studies that show that young men
entering fraternities become much more
likely to commit sexual assault and so
unfortunate that UVA the UVA a Rolling
Stone report botched that investigation
but you know I'm obviously signaling out
fraternities but what other institutions
are on your radar both within the campus
context and without thank you so much
well that was a great question so as you
mentioned yeah we do a lot of work
within the college realm but we also do
work in other closed institutions such
as the military
they've taken great strides and they've
consulted with us at tossa in getting
that getting work done there we also
have worked a lot with groups from the
faith-based community so we are working
across the board to address these issues
especially how they relate to again it
was closed with closed institutions that
there's a there is a different dynamic
there's an added level of complexity but
the issue of sexual violence is still
the same and so we have to maneuver
around that and law enforcement law
enforcement is very important to us and
so building and maintaining a
relationship with our law enforcement
specifically campus law enforcement and
giving them access to resources
information training technical
assistance and legal help is a big part
of the work that we do as well so we're
committed to that and that's what we do
sorry what more do you feel can be done
about sexual assault at college campuses
in general right now I'm a big proponent
like I said before preventive education
I think I think I have a line in the
book that we as a like it's a cultural
failure our understanding of consent you
know I would be teaching it in
kindergarten on if I was in charge but
certainly in colleges needs to be doing
that kind of work and I do think when
something has happened and it gets
reported that the focus needs to be as
much on compassion as it is on
compliance I think that also you know
there's this if you have good coaches if
you have coaches who care about this if
you have locker room leaders who care
about this then things change these are
cultural issues but shaping a culture
isn't you know you can just have better
men in those rooms and better men in
those roles who care about this and it
really does make a difference I've met
survivors who have said that you know
one program and one coach did a terrible
job and really foster the culture that
was very abusive and then another
program and another coach did a great
job of making sure that his players
didn't act that way and it really does
in you know in many ways come down to
having the right people who care about
this influencing the men who are going
to be committing those actions
Ferdinando thank you all so much for
participating and all your great
questions thank you so much we'll be at
the booth okay I'm gonna go like pushed
away here
[Music]
[Applause]
then you're watching book TV on c-span
to live coverage of the Texas Book
Festival and our coverage will continue
shortly next up
Mary Beth Rogers and Josh King discussed
their books on campaign strategy we'll
be right back
[Music]
here's a look at some authors recently
featured on book TVs afterwards our
weekly author interview program Columbia
University Law Professor Tim woo
explained the ways society has been
affected by advertising former goldman
sachs vice-president julissa r say
described her experience as an
undocumented immigrant and Temple
University professor Sarah goldrich
Rebbe explained possible solutions to
rising college tuition costs in the
coming weeks on afterwards Harvard
University economist George Boras will
talk about his research on the impact of
immigration on the US economy Gary Young
editor at large for The Guardian will
discuss his investigation of gun
violence in America also coming up
Washington Post columnist Sebastian
Mallaby will talk about the career of
former Federal Reserve Chairman Alan
Greenspan and this weekend Bain Capital
co-founder Edward Connard argues that
income inequality contributes to
economic growth those synergies were
created gradually over time through
successful risk-taking that bubbled up
from a much larger pool of failed
risk-taking so I think we always have
the option of we can tax and distribute
more in the short run but we slow down
the growth and in the long run look at
the difference between the growth rate
of the United States and Europe look at
the difference between the income levels
of the United States and Japan there
they get bigger and bigger and bigger
and the differences get bigger and
bigger and the ability for those
countries to catch up now that they've
fallen behind it's unlikely that they
can catch up unless we have a major
shift in technology say to biology or or
something else besides really I think
we're heading towards consciousness with
computers and the internet and we have a
a big advantage that maybe we can't
sustain forever but we certainly have a
big competitive advantage today
afterwards airs on book TV every
Saturday at 10:00 p.m. and Sunday at
9:00 p.m. Eastern you can watch all
previous afterwards programs on our web
site book TV org
while there are 3,000 students in the
overall study the bank really focuses on
six of them just to try to help the
reader understand what this looks like
up close and that was really one of my
tasks was these students have gone
through enormous challenges and I want
the reader to be able to really see them
so consider someone like Chloe Chloe was
a young woman who grew up on a farm you
know in rural Wisconsin and had a horse
and thought it would be really cool when
I'm older to be able to take care of
animals which i think is you know a
pretty normal ambition and she went off
to a two-year college so that she could
do that while so many people think that
community college is free in this
country
Chloe was one of those who quickly
figured out that that was not true so
she had very little money
her family was assessed by the federal
government to be able to only pay a
couple thousand dollars a year for
college but even after all her grants
came due she was facing a bill of over
ten thousand dollars a year and she was
asking herself how am I supposed to do
that and by the way just because the
federal government says my mom can
contribute that two thousand dollars
she can't they're wrong so Chloe sold
her horse to go to college that was the
starting point to me that was such a
poignant example of the extremes that
students will go to because they want
that education yeah and she really did
want it and I you know I don't think
that she's an anomaly because I think
that sometimes what happens is grandma's
sell something or the cousins pitch in
something families go to great lengths
to make college possible for their
students these days so but even with
that money Chloe wasn't okay so what she
did was she knew about student loans but
she wanted to try to avoid them because
her mother was struggling with a lot of
credit card debt and Chloe was really
afraid of ending up in that circumstance
so instead she took on not one job but
two jobs and the reason was because she
couldn't get enough hours from this from
a single employer so she worked at
Kohl's which is the department store in
Wisconsin and she also worked at
Petsmart which makes a lot of sense for
what she was trying to do in school and
she found herself doing those two jobs
and doing what so many reformers will
tell her
do which is to take five classes at a
time to try to get done quickly to jobs
and five classes do not add up
she was commuting back and forth running
all over the place and she started to
find herself falling asleep in class and
again she knew that she was exerting too
much energy and that she wasn't doing
enough studying but by the time she said
okay this isn't gonna work for me and I
need other money and she applied for a
student loan
well student loans don't just come
through immediately right it took more
than a month for the loan money to
arrive and by that point her grades were
so bad that she had been placed on
academic probation and these days Chloe
is no longer in college she has debt and
no degree
here's a look at some of the staff pics
from the Harvard bookstore in Cambridge
Massachusetts Yahoo News political
columnist Matt Bai explores how the
downfall of Gary Hart's presidential
campaign has shaped today's campaigns in
all the truth is out Supreme Court
Justice Stephen Breyer looks at how some
of the High Court's decisions are
stretching beyond America's borders in
the court and the world in 1944
historian Jay Winik reviews the
decisions FDR had to make regarding
d-day and the end of World War two
journalist Jenny Nordberg reports on the
lives of Afghan women and girls in the
underground girls of Kabul another staff
pick from the Harvard bookstore is black
man in a white coat by dr. Damon Tweedy
who weighs in on race and inequalities
in the American health care system in we
should all be feminists Chimamanda Ngozi
Adichie argues that everyone should be
fighting for gender equality Brandeis
University English professor John BIRT
died sex the seven debates between
Abraham Lincoln and Stephen Douglas
during their 1858 US Senate seat race in
Lincoln's tragic pragmatism and Beryl
Markham reveals the difficulties she
faced as a career pilot and as the first
woman to fly solo across the Atlantic
Ocean in her memoir West with the night
at some of the staff picks from the
Harvard bookstore in Cambridge
Massachusetts
many of these authors have appeared on
book TV you can watch them on our web
site book tv.org
so it turns out that Lorena and Eleanor
exchanged over 3,000 letters and most of
them Lorena Hickok gave to the FBI a
library in Hyde Park when she died in
1968 and Larina
who was hick too everybody stipulated
that the letters could be open ten years
after her death by chance
Doris Faber was the one who first saw
the letter she had written a lot of
children's books about presidents and
presidents wives and she was horrified
she even tried to get the library to
lock the letters up again but when they
wouldn't she decided to write a book
about the relationship playing down the
passionate part of the story so when the
book came out a lesbian publication
called Big Mama reg lamented that
turning those letters over to Doris
Faber was a crime akin to turning over
suppose poems to medieval Christian
theologians so I realized right away
that this was an opportunity to revisit
a story in changed times and here's
where writing about what you can connect
to came into it so all my books with one
exception that book about research have
been about strong remarkable women
Karen Horne I was the first the
psychoanalyst who took issue with
Freud's ideas about sexuality Marie
Curie and even the theater book focused
on a one strong woman who was the head
of the federal theater project a woman
named Howie Flanagan so and there was
another reason that I connected to this
even though the love relationship had
been floating around in the atmosphere
times had changed and this was a story
that could be embraced even celebrated
about two women who loved and empowered
each other
[Music]
and beginning now from the Texas Book
Festival in Austin a discussion on
campaign strategy